hi there Steve here now for the 12th in
this series this course on how to get
how to achieve a breakthrough in your
language learning and in a way I think
this is the most important message
language learning is something that we
do all of our lives the brain is a
learning machine and it learns all the
time it doesn't matter whether you're
ten thirty fifty or seventy three like
me right now I'm learning Arabic and
Persian and I intend to learn more
languages language learning is something
that we carry with us all of our lives
if we're interested and so the key is to
be motivated interested and maintain a
positive attitude so one thing to
remember is don't worry about what you
aren't able to do in the language think
about what you have already achieved
when we feel positive about our
accomplishments we want to do more of
the same we are surrounded today with
the means of learning languages that
didn't exist fifty years ago when I was
studying Chinese for example we have the
internet we have portable devices and
I'm forever doing my linked lessons on
my iPad if I go down to the gym I have
my ipod touch I listen with my I don't
gonna be promoting Apple products
there's lots of others similar products
out there my ear plots but I also buy
books that interest me in Arabic or in
Farsi and there's so much to explore in
language learning but the key is to make
it enjoyable I don't recommend unless
you really want to don't do all these
grammar drills and exercises where you
keep on getting things wrong it doesn't
encourage you at least doesn't encourage
me I might review grammar but I don't
expect to remember anything that I
reviewed mostly I rely on exposing my
brain to the language massive listening
reading occasional review
of words and phrases the way we do it
linked through your various activities
occasionally checking up something that
I'm curious about that relates to the
grammar of the language but not again
not trying to nail anything down I make
it an enjoyable exploration of the
language and if we do that then we'll
want to continue we may want to continue
to improve in length in one language or
we may decide that even though we are
less than perfect in language a we want
to explore language B and we may go back
to language aid so it should always be a
pleasurable voyage of discovery and we
can all learn there's no such thing as a
special talent for language learning
people in some countries like countries
where the language their language is not
widely spoken Finland
Liston Stein Holland they tend to be
better at learning languages because
they have a better attitude so language
learning is not about talent we all
learn our first language we can all
learn more languages it's about attitude
so I encourage you to take away from the
this sort of 12 lesson course that it's
important to be confident that you can
learn the language try to find things
that you enjoy in terms of content in
terms of activity do things that you
enjoy and then feel confident that the
kind of language learning activity
you're engaged in is going to help you
don't second-guess what you're doing why
am i studying this way don't
second-guess why you're even spending
time with the language if you are
convinced that it is something you want
to do and you are convinced that it is
that you're using a method that's
effective and if you feel that you will
eventually learn the language even
though it takes a long time you know
it's not a 100-yard dash it's a long
distance run you will eventually get
there and perhaps develop an attitude
towards language learning that stays
with you
your life so thank you for listening and
good luck in your language learning
activities bye for now